You taking me to school again? -And picking you up.
Daddy...
What is that, a part of some drill?
Ain't no drill.
19 men attacked our country. The 12 of you will be the first ones to fight back.
How do you love your family and leave them to go to war?
I have two hours, I'll be really quick. -Not a chance.
Holding out is the only way I can guarantee you come back to me.
Well, it's gonna be only a week.
I don't care how long you're gone, as long as you come back.
We got one, two, three, four!
Every step, we take he's gonna be in a minefield from a hundred different wars.
Odds are, we're not all gonna make it out of this.
If we don't take that city, the World Trade Center, it's just the beginning.
We're teaming up the general of the Northern Alliance that we know nothing about.
General, you show me exactly where we're going.
Over the mountains. We take horses.
Alright, who's ridden before? Anyone?
Summer camp, when I was nine.
Spring break, but I was pretty hammered
Does it have a name? The name?
Great, this will be fun.
We're outnumbered. Fifty thousand Taliban Al-Qaeda fighters.
We're on our own. I can't order anyone to do this.
Do you want to surrender?
Keep your finger on the trigger.
Just stay there.
Oh, God.
There's no playbook here, we have to write it ourselves.
I ain't losing one man on this team.
We're fighting with horsemen against tanks.
The greatest weapon in history, is this.
If you die, that's a letter you and your wife are gonna wish you wrote.
I made you a promise. I'm coming home.